since I last spoke to you from this
podium we've continued to make progress
nationally against the virus we are now
reporting regularly fewer than 1000 new
cases each day the Office for National
Statistics estimates that between the
14th and of June and the 27th of June
the most recent period they have
analyzed 25,000 people in the community
in England had the virus one person in
every 2,200
saij assessed that the our rate the
average number of people each infected
person passes the virus on to remains
between nine point seven and nine point
nine across the UK
saij also assessed that in England the
number of new infections is shrinking by
between two and five percent every day
and while the number of people dying
with coronavirus remains too high the
numbers do continue to fall now of
course this picture is not universal
there are areas such as Leicester where
the virus is still more prevalent than
we would like we always said there would
be local outbreaks requiring local
action this is to be expected and will
I'm afraid be a feature of our lives for
some time to come but that should not
take away from the great progress we've
made together as a country against this
vicious disease this progress is the
reason why we've been able slowly
carefully cautiously to ease the
national lockdown
without doubt lockdown has saved many
hundreds of thousands of lives but it
has also had a devastating impact on our
way of life and our economy and of
course lockdown has not yet been lifted
entirely indoor gyms nail bars swimming
pools are still closed mass mass
gatherings are still provided a social
distancing is still essential I want
these restrictions to be lifted as soon
as possible
of course I didn't we've established
task forces to work rapidly and closely
with the sectors that remain closed to
explore how they can be coded secure and
I'm pleased to report that a good
progress is being made
next week we will set out a timetable
for their reopening though of course I
can only lift those remaining national
restrictions as and when it is safe to
do so our goal remains to enable as many
people as possible to live their lives
as close to normally as possible in a
way which is as fair and as safe as
possible and to achieve this we need to
move away from blanket national measures
to targeted local measures so instead of
locking down the whole country we will
lock down specific premises or local
areas where the virus is spreading
instead of closing down non-essential
retail and hospitality nationwide we
will only shut establishments locally as
required instead of shutting all schools
for most pupils from September we will
only shut those schools where it is
absolutely necessary to control an
outbreak and instead of quarantine
arrivals from the whole world
we will only quarantine arrivals from
those countries where the viruses sadly
and not yet under control were already
implementing this targeted approach in
England in weston-super-mare we
identified an outbreak in a hospital
closed it to visitors and new admissions
tested all staff and patients and gave
the hospital a deep-clean the outbreak
was contained and the hospital is open
again in Kirklees we identified night
break at a meatpacking plant shut down
the plant moved in a mobile testing unit
tested all employees and traced the
contacts of those who were positive the
outbreak was contained and the plant has
reopened with additional safety measures
place and of course more recently in
Leicester we identified a community-wide
outbreak which was not restricted to a
single location unlike Western Super
mayor and Kirklees public health England
engaged with the local authority mobile
testing units were deployed full data
was shared cancer-y data was shared on
the 11th of June postcode level data was
shared last week this enhanced
monitoring through additional testing
showed that the infection rate in
Leicester was three times the next
highest infection rate in any other city
in the country so on Monday the health
secretary announced a local lockdown
measures in Leicester fir in it an
initial period of two weeks in each of
these cases the problems identified were
specific to weston-super-mare Kirklees
and Leicester so of course it made sense
to take action locally rather than
reimpose restrictions on the whole
country we're learning the whole time
with each local outbreak we see what
works well and what not so well so that
we do better next time
informed by our experience of these
cases we've developed an approach for
controlling future local outbreaks which
has five principal components monitoring
engagement testing targeted restrictions
and finally as a last resort lockdown
first monitoring public health England
working with the joint biosecurity
Centre will examine carefully data on
the spread of the disease and people's
behavior across the country they will
look out for emerging trends rising case
numbers and other indicators or taking
into account local factors critically we
have made local data available to all
directors of Public Health in local
authorities so they too can monitor
what's happening in their area and local
data will also be available to the
public on the garba
UK dashboard second
engagement if monitoring identifies
local problems NHS tests and trace and
public health England will work with the
relevant local authority to develop a
deeper understanding of the problem and
identify solutions working with local
agencies we will seek to keep the local
community informed at every stage so
they know what's happening and what
actions if any they need to take third
testing we now have substantial testing
capacity nationwide and we have the
ability to target that capacity at local
areas in order to get a grip on emerging
outbreaks scaled up testing at a local
level
combined with contract tastes contact
tasting at testing tracing on forgiving
contact contract contact tracing through
NHS tests and trace can control the
virus and thus avoid more stringent
measures fourth targeted restrictions if
the virus continues to spread we will
restrict activities of particular
locations and close individual premises
as in weston-super-mare and Kirklees we
will restrict access to places which
become hotspots for the virus while
testing people who have spent time in
those places and tracing the contacts of
anyone who test positive fifth local
lockdown if the previous measures have
not proven to be enough we will
introduce local lock downs extending
across whole communities as in Leicester
that could mean shutting down business
venues that would otherwise be opened
closing schools or urging people once
more to stay at home local lock downs
will be carefully calibrated depending
on the scientific the specific
circumstances of each outbreak and we
are continually exploring smarter means
of containing the
virus so that is the approach we will
take as local outbreaks occur and we
will set out more detail soon let me end
by looking forward to this weekend
tomorrow there will be a moment of
remembrance for those who have lives who
have tragically been lost before their
time at and at 5 p.m. on Sunday the NHS
is 72nd birthday we can all come
together to clap those who have worked
tirelessly and selflessly to help the
nation get through this pandemic I know
everyone will be looking forward to the
relaxation of national restrictions as
lockdown eases we should focus on
supporting the livelihoods of business
owners and their employees up and down
the country all of whom are opening
their doors for the first time in more
than three months they are our local
restaurants hairdressers libraries
museums cinemas and yes pups
they're also our hotels B and B's indeed
much of our tourism industry all these
businesses and their workers have put in
a heroic effort to prepare their venues
for this reopening to work out a way to
trade that keeps their customers safe
but the success of these businesses the
livelihoods of those who rely on them
and ultimately the economic health of
the whole country is dependent on every
single one of us acting responsibly we
must not let them down lock down only
succeeded in controlling the virus
because everyone worked together and we
will only succeed in reeling if everyone
works together again because we're not
out of the woods yet
the virus is still with us and the spike
in Lester has shown that if it starts
running out of control again this
government will not hesitate in putting
on the brakes and reimposing
restrictions anyone who flout social
distancing and kovat secure rules is not
only putting us all at risk but letting
down those businesses and workers who
have done so much to prepare for this
new normal so as we take this next step
our biggest step yet on the road to
recovery I urge the British people to do
so safely
remember don't gather in groups of more
than six outside or two households in
any setting keep your distance from
those outside your household two metres
if you can one meter with precautions if
you can't wash your hands let's all stay
alert control the virus save lives and
enjoy summer safely